[Musique]
bonsoir à tous le satis culture se met
ce soir en mode club electro nous sommes
devant un la salle du vieux marché à
jouy en josas pour le festival électro
chic voici le sommaire la musique
électro mise à l'honneur au festival
électro chic du 10 au 19 mars versailles
grand parc organise sa 6e édition nous
avons assisté à la soirée de lancement
l'éphémère c'est le thème de la 24e
édition du printemps des poètes qui se
déroulera du 12 au 26 mars saint quentin
en yvelines est partenaire de
l'événement parmi les temps forts une
performance poétique à la commanderie
des templiers à elancourt et enfin c'est
le premier salon du livre de saint
quentin en yvelines les 1er et 2 avril
au vélodrome nationale plus de 80
auteurs seront présents
[Musique]
je me trouve dans la salle étudié marché
à jouy en josas l'un des vieux
partenaire du festival électro chic cet
événement qui met en lumière la musique
électro se déroule du 10 au 19 mars
christine palau bonjour enfin bon soir
plutôt vous êtes la directrice de la
culture à versailles au grand parc alors
aussi la sixième édition du festival en
quoi elle est différente des années
précédentes alors elle est différente
d'abord parce qu'on est vraiment très
heureux d'être ici après deux années
absolument exceptionnelle et en plus un
peu d'émotion puisque on a arrêté le
festival l'année dernière pile avec les
premières restrictions et le confinement
mais elle est exceptionnelle aussi parce
qu'on accueille vraiment des artistes de
grande renommée internationale qui pour
certains attendent deux éditions pour
pouvoir se produire sur scène et puis on
accueille deux nouvelles communes dans
notre aventure valley et bois d'arcy
donc avec une programmation d'une
dizaine d'artistes sûr c'est six jours
de festival justement on va parler de la
programmation des nouveaux rendez vous
avec des concerts des dj sets
justement quelle est la programmation et
est ce que finalement ce ne sont que des
artistes électro alors ce sont tous des
lacs des artistes électro mais qui sont
emblématiques de toutes les branches de
l'électro c'est un univers qui est
extrêmement riche et foisonnant et donc
effectivement on va avoir une
exploration de l'électro orientale comme
de la techno comme de la transe comme ce
soir peut-être un peu plus de la hausse
donc on a tous les univers et avec des
mélanges de musique électro à partir
d'instruments analogique d'instruments
électroniques et d'instruments
acoustiques mais parmi ces différents
artistes que vous n'avez cité lba à car
là bas tu étais l'un des musiciens
invités sur le festival voyez ce
reportage
m
ils étaient environ 300 à écouter son dj
set lba cas labat a mixé de minuit à 2h
du matin dans la salle du clae marché à
jouy en josas pour le festival électro
chic il est heureux de retrouver son
public j'ai joué il ya deux semaines à
paris c'était cool c'était la première
la reprise et puis là ça reprend juste
important recul depuis décembre j'ai pas
joué là demain je vais à bruxelles donc
c'est pour ses tickets producteur
lyonnais repart en tournée pour faire
découvrir ses nouveaux sont des
exclusivités de son label ou des titres
à succès il a débuté sa carrière en 2008
il définit sa musique comme club dance
music entre techno et house
[Musique]
un moment faire donc enfin été dj fly
scratch et j'ai hérité des platines des
vignes et les ça commençait comme toi ce
collectionneur de vinyles sample de
multiples sont ils utilisent un extrait
sonore déjà enregistrés pour l'intégrer
dans un nouveau morceau chez lui nba cas
là bas tu écoutes des disques
complètement différent les disques de
jazz de soul de funk disco kraut rock
spirituel du brésil je sens
des vieux 10 des années soixante dix
pour en faire des morceaux un peu plus
électro des élites à cette soirée était
présent également d'autres dj comme
l'association tva qui réunit des
passionnés de musique électronique ou
encore le collectif stop motion parmi
les autres rendez-vous mot cadeau en
concert à versailles vendredi 18 mars ou
encore même date mowgli à la fabrique à
bois d'arcy sans oublier milla dietrich
en clôture dimanche 20 mars à londres et
10 villacoublay alors viens de voir le
sujet il n'y a pas que el berka labat
qui qui était ce soir ici est ce que
vous pouvez me citer peut-être d'autres
artistes alors dans les grands noms à
des artistes qui aujourd'hui se produit
sur scène depuis 25 10 15 ans vous allez
retrouver bien sûr arnaud rebotini qui
est une des grandes têtes d'affiché du
festival et qui re sera reçu à londres à
vélizy villacoublay
à ses côtés la très grande si minagri
gorioux donc une des reines des clubs
berlinois la jeune mia dietrich qui est
aussi très dans la musique trance on va
aussi retrouver thierry balasse avec
julien renouons qui est un
électroacousticien beaucoup plus
habitués aux spectacles de théâtre
musique au mellah qui va vraiment être
accueillis pour un projet de musique
électro et puis on va avoir aussi des
jeunes artistes ou des artistes
émergents qui se produisent depuis
quelques années on a le très grand
plaisir d'accueillir mot cadeau à
versailles à la nef de les grands de
l'école d'architecturé qui sort son
nouvel album exactement en ce moment
médium douce à bailly et puis des plus
jeunes qui sont en train de se découvrir
et bien sûr le tremplin à l'undd à
vélizy donc y aura lieu samedi en
ouverture on a eu 60 candidats donc là
la sélection était très dense mais je
vous promets vraiment d'avoir des
figures très prometteuse et des axes
très différents je sais pas vous parler
du tremplin c'est que c'est qu'est-ce
que si finalement tremplin de jeunes
talents comment ça va se dérouler alors
donc ce tremplin c'est une idée de joël
15 burget le directeur du théâtre avec
cette idée de promouvoir des talents de
la musique électro qui n'ont pas
forcément été déjà repéré par des
producteurs donc on leur demande de
postuler avec deux de leurs créations et
une reprise donc cette année une reprise
d'arnaud rebotini un peu notre parrain
de ce festival
et puis ils sont donc cinq d'entre eux
ont été sélectionnés ils se produiront
sur scène il y aura donc un 1
un vote du public et un vote d'un jury
de professionnels pour désigner le grand
gagnant est grand gagnant qui se
produira l'année prochaine pour la
nouvelle et dit c'est toujours comme ça
c'est toujours comme ça cette année nous
avons deux gagnants du tremplin de la
session 5 puisque en fait on avait eu un
enthousiasme tels des internautes sur
internet puisque le tremplin pu avoir
lieu en ligne l'an dernier donc entre
les envies des internautes et du et du
corps professionnel on a décidé d'en
nommer deux donc cash pony club et à
yann perreau est alors pour cette
sixième édition à huile yeux
indifférents sont proposés comment vous
les avez sélectionné alors ces lieux en
fait c'est eux qui se propose notre
aventure de communauté d'agglomération
c'est bien de faire proposer quelque
chose avec nos communes et donc ce sont
les communes qui envie de proposer une
programmation en s'inscrivant dans la
ligne globale et c'est ensemble en
collaboration qu'on a sur cette
programmation est donc eux contribuer au
festival donc on est très heureux de les
accueillir et plus nombreux ition mieux
ce sera pour les publics c'est noté
merci beaucoup christine vallot
d'apprécier la réalité merci
[Musique]
on va parler de poésie à présent
saint-quentin-en-yvelines participe une
nouvelle fois au printemps au dépôt est
cette année c'est le printemps de
l'éphémère du 12 au 26 mars au programme
des rencontres avec des artistes parmi
les temps forts à la commanderie une
performance poétique était organisée
[Musique]
autre chose
premier rendez vous du printemps des
poètes l'auteur laurent colons et la
lectrice frédérique bruyas sont
interprétées samedi 12 mars une
performance poétique j'ai créé une sorte
de recueil de monologues de poésie qu'on
a augmenté frédéric et moi d'autres
textes qui proviennent d'autres
spectacles sur l'appropriation de la
langue française notamment auprès des
migrants j'ai beaucoup travaillé avec
des migrants donc il ya un rapport à la
halle aux langues étrangères qui est
très présent c'est en fait une création
vraiment pour ce thème éphémère qui
s'appelle a eu une éphéméride de
l'expression
un voyage aux couleurs de la france et
du japon joué par le duo pour
sensibiliser le public au thème de cette
édition l'éphémère la parole par essence
est éphémère 10 par an ou séparés sans
les mots disparaissent à peine ils sont
prononcés s'enfuit il s'enfuit on dit
c'est excellent être de la bible les
écrits restent et les paroles s'envolent
[Musique]
le printemps des poètes c'est depuis
2002 à la commanderie de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines quinze jours
de célébration des mots et leurs auteurs
le programme du printemps des poètes à
saint quentin en yvelines c'est une
variété est vraiment un petit aperçu de
ce qu'est la poésie qui touche tellement
de domaines
donc moi j'ai proposé un panel et ce
soir c'est au tour du langage autre date
une soirée caribéenne le 19 mars et un
concert du poète slameur orphée le 26
mars deux autres rendez-vous de
l'éphémère pourtant prêt à rester dans
les mémoires du public
enfin quentin en yvelines le premier
salon du livre aura lieu les 1er et 2
avril prochain au vélodrome nationale
près de 80 auteurs sont à découvrir et
des séances dédicaces ouverte organisée
[Musique]
saint quentin en yvelines c'est une une
agglomération qui est tournée sur le
futur sur thomas sur l'innovation sur le
numérique et en même temps le livre
garde une place importante au fond c'est
rendu compte pendant la pandémie
notamment qu'il y avait une véritable
affection pour ce support finalement qui
peut paraître un petit peu désuet à
montrer finalement qu'il ne l'était pas
[Musique]
le salon pour le grand public va
commencer le vendredi soir donc
notamment avec des scènes live le thème
de ce salon c'était les visionnaires
donc ces basses et comment on envisage
le futur l'avenir dans tous les
registres henry le samedi donc avec la
remise du prix du livre de saint quentin
en yvelines remise du prix donc avec le
jury
et bien évidemment plusieurs débats qui
comportait donc sur les thèmes de demain
y aura des séances de dédicaces il ya
des auteurs qui viendront échanger avec
le public notamment jeudi 2 lors du café
d'auteur le le sable le vendredi après
midi et aussi le samedi dans la journée
[Musique]
le président du jury basse et guillaume
martin alors guillaume martin c'est pas
n'importe qui c'est un cycliste de haut
niveau mais en même temps c'est un
philosophe ils se baptisent lui-même un
petit peu comme vélos sauf
il a écrit il écrivait il écrit toujours
des critiques au niveau du monde il a
écrit un livre qui s'appelle socrates à
vélo
[Musique]
côté expositions dans les yvelines le
perray-en-yvelines présente son salon
des arts une centaine d'artistes
régionaux et nationaux dévoilent leurs
oeuvres du 28 mars au 3 avril dans la
salle des fêtes de la maraude ou la
galerie elle serait de vie met en avant
les oeuvres d'aurélie ernaux entre
photographie peinture et croquis
l'artiste présente sa vision du monde
et c'est la fin de cette 8 e cultura
merci de nous avoir suivis rendez vous
et la semaine prochaine dans un autre
lieu culturel yvelinois bonne soirée sur
tv5 118
[Musique]